es posible que a usted oa alguien que
conoce le hayan diagnosticado diabetes
tipo 2 este vídeo le ayudará a
comprender qué es y por qué es
importante mantenerla bajo control
la diabetes tipo 2 es una afección en la
que su nivel de azúcar en sangre es
demasiado alto los hidratos de carbono
son sustancias que su cuerpo utiliza
para fabricar energía después de comer
alimentos que contienen hidratos de
carbono estos finalmente van a su
intestino delgado en su intestino
delgado el alimento se descompone en
moléculas de azúcar únicas llamadas
glucosa
las células de su intestino delgado
absorben los azúcares que pasan al flujo
sanguíneo cuando la sangre llega al
páncreas detecta la alta cantidad de
azúcar en su sangre
normalmente esto provoca que su páncreas
coloque una sustancia química llamada
insulina en su flujo sanguíneo la
insulina reduce la cantidad de azúcar en
su sangre a un nivel saludable
como lo hace la insulina
a medida que la sangre se mueve a través
de su cuerpo la insulina y el azúcar
salen del flujo sanguíneo y se meten en
sus tejidos para llegar a sus células la
mayoría de las células tienen
estructuras en sus superficies llamadas
receptores de insulina cuando la
insulina fluye por ahí se adhiere a los
receptores
la insulina actúa como una llave en una
cerradura para abrir la célula
y permitir que el azúcar pueda ingresar
en su interior ahora su célula puede
usar el azúcar para fabricar la energía
que necesita para trabajar de manera
apropiada y su nivel de azúcar en sangre
cae de regreso a su rango normal
si tiene diabetes tipo 2 sus células no
responden a la insulina como deberían
esto se denomina resistencia a la
insulina
cuando esto sucede su insulina no puede
abrir las células para que dejen entrar
el azúcar porque falta la cerradura o
receptores de insulina o no está
funcionando
como resultado el azúcar se queda afuera
de sus células
cuando el azúcar no puede ingresar a sus
células se acumula en su flujo sanguíneo
esta es una afección llamada
hiperglucemia
en respuesta a los altos niveles de
azúcar en sangre su páncreas produce más
y más insulina las células sobrecargadas
de su páncreas intentan mantenerse al
ritmo
pero lentamente pierden su capacidad
para producir suficiente insulina estos
problemas pueden llevar a los síntomas
de la diabetes tipo 2
si tiene preguntas sobre la diabetes
tipo 2 o cualquier medicamento que le
hayan recetado hable con su médico
es importante que tome sus medicamentos
como se lo indicó su médico
cuéntele sobre cualquier efecto
secundario que tenga